so how has the Dancing with the Stars
experience been for you Z Shield
specifically since it's your first time
yeah I mean it's been pretty amazing um
obviously at first I was a bit like
nervous just like oh my gosh I don't
know what this is gonna be like and then
of course like once you get to know
everybody it's it's like family here and
just within the crew you can really tell
that you know some of them have been
there since the very beginning that's
how you really know that like not only
is the production good but like everyone
is truly feels like a family and it's
pretty awesome to see that kind of
connection you know it kind of reminds
me of you know Marvel sets where you'll
see that like some hair and makeup
people have been in the business and
doing the same you know thing for years
and years and you're like wow seems like
everyone's a family here you know so I
had those buts and yeah just B it's been
pretty great
obviously and Val how's it how has it
been working with zoil it it's been
wonderful she you know she's a great
student a great partner somebody that is
very thoughtful and works hard and loves
the experience and she's seen the show
it's very excited to be a part of the
show and is now squeezing every ounce of
this experience well it's so crazy I
actually like I really enjoyed the show
I used to watch it with my grandma all
the time and so it's funny to see like
you know certain people like Val and
then Max and like ardam and seeing and
Peta like seeing all these people that
I've like watched on screen um kind of
seeing them like it's it's almost like
in my own way a little bit of like
seeing a famous celebrity but it's not a
like not an actor it's like a ball
dancer which I think is funny absolutely
no it makes total sense and you like you
said you have these core memories right
so it's like fill fillment life
fulfillment
right awesome so what has been the
biggest challenge for you both as
partners oh his description of
fun our challenges change week you know
always surprises yeah first it was that
and then it was just getting injured
it's just like why it's just health
health has been challenged but
then that's it feel like there haven't
been many challenges and I like it that
way that's good I think there's uh
there's the obvious challenges of
everyday work and showing up and
obviously it's hard and dog I want to be
here every day but yeah those are
challenges that you take on willingly
then there are challenges like you know
landing on your ankle doing something
else or getting hurt
or you know other things that come up
along the way as you create you know
this is a real collaboration in real
time a live two hours of live television
uh and so you're collaborating with
departments along the way things happen
things change you know these are
challenges that have come up that you
know are under need the surface that you
never never really get to see um our
packages before the dance try to expose
some of the process but you really you
really don't get to see a lot of it so
um yeah there's always challeng
makes sense so who do you both feel I
want to hear from both of you who do you
feel is your biggest competition in in
in the current
competition referring to the previous
question all those challenges yeah we
are I think we're competing with just
the fact that we're in season 32 uh
you've seen every single version of
every single possible dance uh and so
we're the challenge for us is to try to
is mind our own little lane you know to
do things that haven't been done risks
to wear things to
Showcase music or Styles or cultures
that otherwise would have never arrived
on this dance floor and so that's the
challenges like how how does this Dan
not just separate us from the
competition this season but ultimately
just show all yeah nice nice so
tonight's Whitney night are youall
Whitney Houston
fans yeah yes of course okay that's the
only right answer
so yeah she's also a
fashion F icon cute little jacket you
know I think
it she used to wear jackets oh yeah she
she was an incredible human being um so
I I am looking forward to seeing y'all
dance tonight to some Whitney um H how
are you feeling about the dance off
though yeah it's kind of weird not going
to lie you know because literally a week
ago charity and I were on the same team
and so it's like you know changing
perspective of rooting for each other
and supporting one another and being at
rehearsal and being like goofing around
about whatever dumb dance move that we
were both like freaking out over to like
now having to like okay I'mma see you
out there on the Dance Floor you know
it's like a different mind but it's fun
you know at the same time it's like all
playful and fun we everyone really likes
one another so it's not necessarily like
mean competition but like fun
competition that's good I'm glad to hear
that because you it it I imagine it
makes you feel more relaxed even going
into the like one
onone you know say a little bit of like
trash talk but it's not really like real
and you know no matter what it's just
really fun to be out there dancing
alongside her like like I just think
that's really fun it reminds me of just
like events and stuff where I'd like
kind of hang out with my friends and
dance it's just we're being compared to
my mother that's not of our
business yeah that's on them that's not
on y'all that's on
them wait what is what does ballroom
dance Trash Talk sound like I'm very
curious is the same trash talk just with
a British aing
bro I like that I like that
I'm a it was the what was it the
ch ch challenge
accepted that is an excellent dad joke
like good old pun we love a pun here um
that's gonna I'm gonna use that later um
so your partnership has been really fun
to watch and I've really enjoyed I'm
excited like I said earlier I'm excited
to watch y'all tonight um how uh this is
my last question and it's for soel how
do you how does the physicality here
compare to the Marvel physicality like
how does it compare what's harder what's
easier it's just different it's very
different um you know because
with Marvel I had martial arts
background you know so that helped me
and that got me through a lot of it and
I didn't necessarily feel like there was
things I hadn't before you know I mostly
felt pretty comfortable in that space
and here it's like I don't really know
dance like I don't know how to dance I
just kind of goof around and it's about
it you know so coming into this I was
just like okay I can only learn as much
as I can via the show you know because
each week you have to watch the pro
dancer explain the first like basic
steps you know so that's kind of
basically all my knowledge was watching
and just knowing that and so that's the
only difference is that I didn't know
too much going into that which Mak laugh
me very depending on this
guy I've done I've done things on TV
where whether it's choreography actually
had to choreograph a Tango scene in
which a there's like a little fight
scene that happens and you know a phone
is being exchanged Etc and that was
really cool because you you get to I
mean obviously you have more takes and
there's different parameters when you're
filming for TV versus like live versus
uh something like a movie uh but working
with the stun choreographer you could
tell like it's the same counting in a
way right so five six seven like
choreography based on counts and timing
uh a lot of flow and I'm excited because
I think she'll be better after this
experience experience I think she will
be better whatever that is whether it's
dance or or martial arts and set any
physical activity I think she's now
gonna go into I hope GNA go into with a
lot more confidence absolutely
and it will I promise you I used to
dance not nearly as good as anybody on
the show ever but the physicality and
the um muscle focus and the isolations
and all of that in dance that you have
to do is it'll help I agree with you Val
it'll
help thank you both so much for taking
the time to chat with me
today
I